[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend eine woche ist es nun her
dass die taliban in kabul einrückten und
die macht in afghanistan damit
vollständig übernahmen seitdem sind die
usa und ihre verbündeten in einer
dramatischen
evakuierungsaktion dabei möglichst viele
menschen aus dem land auszufliegen
verzweiflung gedränge chaos das hat am
flughafen kabul in den letzten tagen 20
todesopfer gefordert die situation
entspannte sich heute nur leicht der
deutsche brigadegeneral arts schilderte
journalisten gegenüber die lage als
weiterhin angespannt und auch die
politische diskussion über versäumnisse
der bundesregierung geht weiter heute
abend so ist aus berlin zu hören soll es
ein krisentreffen im kanzleramt geben
andrea maurer
dass menschen im gedränge vor dem
flughafen gestorben sind dass eltern
ihre kinder in der menge verlieren und
verzweifelt suchen das sind die
nachrichten heute von der evakuierung
operation in kabul in einem briefing mit
der verteidigungsministerin schildert
brigadegeneral alt die lage vor ort
zum darunter gehören die sich darstellt
mit allen dementsprechend bot man was
man dementsprechend ist durchaus mal
politisch geht es weiterhin um die frage
hätte schneller gehandelt werden müssen
fakt ist seit donnerstag nach zwölfter
august war das verteidigungsministerium
über die us vorbereitung einer
evakuierungsaktion informiert der vize
botschafter in kabul soll wochenlang vor
einer verschlechterung der
sicherheitslage gewarnt haben der
aussenminister bestreitet das allerdings
was die frage nach der deutschen
botschaft angeht diese meldung habe ich
gesehen so wie es gemeldet ist oder so
wie es von ihnen dargestellt worden es
ist nicht wichtig der krisenstab der
bundesregierung hat am freitag
beschlossen dass unsere botschaft sich
auf eine evakuierung vorbereitet die
entscheidung zur evakuierung war dann
wohl dramatisch im aktuellen spiegel
heißt es eher zufällig bekommen die
diplomaten der deutschen botschaft in
kabul die dramatischen veränderungen in
ihrer stadt mit es ist samstag 14 august
die amerikaner haben begonnen ihre
schutzkräfte abzuziehen ihre botschaft
zu evakuieren die deutsche botschaft
warnt berlin erst sonntagvormittag kommt
das endgültige go zur evakuierung um 10
uhr 34 setzt der vize botschafter den
prozess wohl selbst in gang wir machen
uns abmarschbereit haben wir grünes
licht das grüne licht sei daraufhin
unverzüglich gekommen sagt das
auswärtige amt das ministerium habe es
verpasst vor die lage zu kommen sagen
beobachter ich glaube sie haben in so
einer situation wenn sie sehen dass
alles das was ihnen bislang geraten
worden ist in genommen durch die
ereignisse
neutralisiert worden ist die möglichkeit
entweder zu sagen ich bleibe meinen
standard prozeduren oder aber ich weiche
davon ab und übernehme die politische
führung und damit natürlich auch die
politische verantwortung das risiko des
scheiterns eigentlich mikro in die hand
der druck auf die regierung wird größer
vor dem kanzleramt haben heute etwa 750
menschen demonstriert eine schnellere
evakuierung gefordert und auch den
wahlkampf haben die möglichen
versäumnisse der regierung längst
erreicht fdp und linke fordern einen
untersuchungsausschuss auch die grüne
kanzlerkandidatin schließt sich dem an
wir müssen das aufarbeiten das was da im
untersuchungsausschuss ja und zwar mit
einem untersuchungsausschuss für die
nächste bundesregierung auch ganz
unabhängig davon wer dann wie diebe
regierung anführt das was an desaster
passiert ist das können wir nicht
einfach verschweigen in kabul kann die
bundeswehr derzeit weniger menschen
evakuieren als noch zu beginn der woche
und das obwohl jeden tag neue namen auf
den listen hinzukommen es gibt einfach
fast kein durchkommen mehr zum retten
den flughafen
hier im studio begrüße ich omid
nouripour bundestagsabgeordneter von den
grünen der sich sehr gut in der region
auskennt vielfach afghanistan bereist
hat und sie halten auch jetzt immer
kontakt nach kabul und ins land schön
genannt erstmal 1 0 wir sehen seit tagen
diese bilder von chaos von drängelei und
irgendwie es kein ende in sicht haben
sie einen eindruck was davon warum das
us militär aber auch die bundeswehr die
situation nicht in den griff bekommen
kann weil es zu spät ist weil das heft
des handelns jetzt bei den taliban nicht
weil sie die kontrolle über die stadt
über die zufahrten zum flughafen haben
und auch nicht raus können aus dem
flughafen und weil es keine möglichkeit
gibt gescheit informationen auch zu
bekommen es gibt ja jetzt ganz wenig
leute draußen die wirklich auch
operative unterwegs sein können um zu
informieren was eigentlich gerade
passiert das heißt die taliban haben
eigentlich fast alles in der hand und
das macht die situation möglich man hat
man den eindruck wenn man das sieht dass
es auf keinen fall bis zum 31 august zu
schaffen ist die menschen
herauszubringen sehen sie irgendeine
möglichkeit der fristverlängerung sie
ist auch sicherlich illusorisch zu
glauben die europäer schaffen das
alleine wenn die amerikaner abgezogen
aber die amerikaner draußen sind ist der
flughafen für uns nicht mehr opera will
dann müssen wir mit rausgehen es sei
denn es gibt eine andere macht die mit
den taliban vereinbart hat den flughafen
laufen zu lassen und die taliban erlaubt
haben dass wir dort bleiben zu preisen
die sie dann diktieren werden deshalb
ist es dringend notwendig jetzt die
gespräche mit den amerikanern zu suchen
und sie zu bitten dass sie so weit wie
möglich so lange wie möglich diesen
flughafen offen halten damit wir weiter
evakuieren können was wir vorher
versäumt hat die
kanzlerin spricht von einer
koordinierten operation man sieht die
koordination nicht so wirklich die
kritik an der bundesregierung ist immens
wir haben das auch gerade wieder gehört
nun waren sie lange zögerlich diese
woche die grünen mit einem
untersuchungsausschuss ihre vorsitzende
kanzlerkandidatin fordert jetzt wird das
was bringen in fünf wochen ist wahr wir
werden sicher keinen
untersuchungsausschuss auf die beine
kriegen mit großen ergebnissen in den
nächsten wochen bis zur wahl aber sie
hat sehr klar und deutlich gesagt und
ich teile das sehr dass wir nach der
wahl spätestens ein
untersuchungsausschuss brauchen um
darüber zu reden wie man die lehren
daraus aufarbeiten kann wie man besser
werden kann aber auch wer die
verantwortung dafür trägt dass dieser
vermeidbare situation jetzt in diese
katastrophe geführt rechnen sie mit
rücktritten nach wenn ich mir angucke
wie gerade die schuldzuweisungen der
bundesregierung hin und her geschoben
werden dann glaube ich das ehrlich
gesagt nicht aber das ist nicht die
hauptsorge die hauptsorge ist dass jetzt
so weit wie möglich so schnell wie
möglich so viele leute wie möglich
herausgeholt das allerdings ist auch die
haltung der bundesregierung
sie kennen das land sehr gut das ja in
den letzten jahrzehnten ein unglaubliche
wechsel des schicksals erlebt hat wir
gucken uns mal diese bilder an die doch
so interessant sind solar sei das land
nämlich tatsächlich auch mal aus in den
60er jahren unter könig schaar gab es
sowas wie ein aufbruch in die moderne
frauen hatten das wahlrecht konnten
studieren bevor dann eben der
bürgerkrieg begann die sowjets kam dann
danach zum ersten mal die taliban die
die frauen einsperrten und unterdrückten
hendry pulver ist eine illusion des
westens in den letzten jahren
diesen freieren zustand von außen
wiederherstellen zu wollen das gab so
viele leute in afghanistan die
mitgeholfen haben es gab ja das
wahlrecht beispielsweise und es gab ja
viele errungenschaften gerade und
speziell für die frauen deshalb ist ja
auch die panne gerade bei denjenigen die
am meisten zu verlieren haben in
afghanistan gerade am größten nämlich
bei den frauen wir haben viel erreicht
die afghanistan aber bei weitem nicht
das was hätte erreicht werden können und
müssen damit das belastbar ist was wir
dort erreicht haben und den letzten
metern gab es noch viel mehr fehler die
oben drauf gekommen sind ich konnte
jetzt viele aus meiner sicht auch führen
es wäre aber dringend notwendig das
alles aufzuarbeiten wissenschaftlichen
unabhängig nun sagen die taliban sie
sind gemäßigt sie geben den frauenrechte
was ist davon zu halten gibt es so etwas
wie gemäßigte taliban meine freunde in
kabul meiner freundinnen in afghanistan
in toto sagen dass sie den taliban kein
wort glauben ich kann mich dem nur
anschließen
die taliban haben 20 jahre gewartet
jetzt müssen sie noch ein zwei wochen
warten bis die amerikaner draußen sind
und sie vermeiden zurzeit bilder die in
washington dazu führen dass die
diskussion neu beginnt ob man vielleicht
doch bleiben möge oder wieder reinkommt
ich glaube die spielen ausschließlich
auf zeit und es gibt ja auch eine
generation war den taliban kommandeuren
eine neue generation die auch
druck zum beispiel von isis und anderem
auch theologisch weit radikaler
aufgewachsen ist das in den 90er jahren
ich glaube nicht dass sie jetzt
moderatorin als früher ich glaube die
sind diszipliniert jetzt wollen die
leute weg nach dem willen der europäer
sollen sie am besten in der region
bleiben deshalb werde man blick in die
region ins nachbarland pakistan wir
haben unseren korrespondenten normen
odenthal gebeten und die rolle pakistans
und seine interessen genauer zu
beschreiben
2640 kilometer lang ist die grenze
zwischen afghanistan und pakistan wo
immer es die berge erlauben hat pakistan
diese grenze in jüngster zeit befestigt
mit hochdruck
90 prozent sind fertig der rest wird vor
ende des sommers fertig sein das ist das
zeitfenster das uns bleibt sonst wird
das wetter zu kalt und die bauarbeiten
werden zu schwierig
mehr als das wetter aber treiben sie
wohl die geschehnisse drüben in
afghanistan an die regierung in
islamabad fürchtet um stabilität in der
region und im eigenen land pakistan hat
den ruf taliban freundlich zu sein auf
eigenem gebiet wollte man sie zwar nicht
gegen oft brutal gegen sie vor aber
jenseits der grenze sah das anders aus
[Musik]
so wurde pakistans rolle immer kritisch
beäugt islamabad galt den usa als
verbündeter der nicht liefert 2018 platz
der präsident trump der twitter kragen
die usa hätten pakistan dummerweise 33
milliarden dollar hilfe gezahlt und
dafür nur lügen zurück bekommen pakistan
bietet terrorgruppen unterschlupf die
von us-truppen in afghanistan gejagt
werden wut hass terror krieg afghanistan
ist der schauplatz doch es ging immer um
mehr viele motive viele mächte die in
ganz südasien um einfluss ringen
pakistans ambitionen etwa auch in
afghanistan waren immer geprägt vom
dauerkonflikt mit dem erz rivalen indien
hätte man sich eine grundlegend andere
politik gegenüber afghanistan betrieben
afghanistan würde immer so als bauer auf
den strategischen schachspiel gegen
indien und das wichtigste er tatsächlich
in afghanistan welche
die ich jedenfalls wird es unter den
radikal islamischen taliban kaum mehr
geben indien das zur bisherigen
regierung in afghanistan ein
ordentliches verhältnis hatte scheint
einer der verlierer pakistans karten
sind jetzt sicher besser aber das spiel
bleibt kompliziert
[Musik]
an der grenze stehen nun pakistanische
soldaten und taliban seite an seite zwei
übergänge sind offen der handel soll
laufen aber ansonsten kommen nur wenige
rein afghanen auf der flucht wurden zwar
visa versprochen aber bisher praktisch
nicht ausgestellt pakistan will abwarten
wie sich die dinge entwickeln und bleibt
vorsichtig vertrauen ist keine währung
in dieser krisenregion vertrauen kann
tödlich sein
ja und das scheint kein ziel nouripour
zu sein für flüchtlinge jedenfalls kein
sicheres ziel sie sind mitglied im
auswärtigen ausschuss in berlin was muss
denn jetzt eigentlich getan werden wenn
auch die bundesregierung möchte dass
flüchtlinge dort bleiben ist mit
pakistan geredet worden ich finde die
ganze debatte nur noch schräg ehrlich
gesagt die leute kommt die gerade nicht
einmal zum nadelöhr kabuler flughafen
und alle reden jetzt was passieren würde
wenn sich millionen menschen auf den weg
machen kann sein dass das noch passiert
aber stand jetzt ist es überhaupt keine
option und die frau bundeskanzlerin und
der vizekanzler sagen wir müssen jetzt
aber mit den nachbarstaaten reden und
denen geld geben wollen sie jetzt dem
iranischen blut richte präsidenten geld
geben damit er die flüchtlinge uns vom
hals hält es ist ganz kompliziert auch
die flüchtlings debatte in diesen
ländern ist sehr kompliziert wir müssen
natürlich uns auf alles vorbereiten was
den letzten jahren nicht passiert ist
aber diese flüchtlings debatte in der
form zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist aus
meiner sicht eine nebelkerze die
ablenkung vom großen scheitern und
versagen dieser regierung und was
passiert in afghanistan und mit
afghanistan wir haben die interessen
gesehen da stehen auch china und
russland in der in der warteschlange
oder schon gar nicht mehr in der
warteschlange was ist ihre prognose ich
glaube dass afghanistan auf drei
bürgerkriege gleichzeitig zu laufen kann
einmal der bürgerkrieg der der
interessen möchte wie sie beschrieben
haben einmal der innogy hat ist ische
weil dieses zum beispiel und die taliban
einander wirklich hassen blutig und
einmal wird das insolvenz geben wir
sehen uns ja jetzt schon dass das
widerstandsgruppen gibt gegen die
taliban kämpfen jede entwicklung dieser
art wird aber ohne uns stattfinden weil
wir uns verabschiedet haben aus dem
gesamten spiel in reborn dankeschön zu
diesem schwierigen thema dank für den
besuch ins studio bank und hier geht es
weiter mit nachrichten und gundula gause
kurz nach gesprächen mit russlands
präsident putin in moskau hat
bundeskanzlerin merkel heute die ukraine
besucht dabei verurteilte sie erneut die
annexion der krim durch russland
gemeinsam mit präsident die lenski
warnte sie moskau außerdem davor die
neue ostseepipeline nord stream zwei als
politische waffe einzusetzen
merkel sagte selensky deutsche
unterstützung für eine weitere nutzung
des leitungssystems in der ukraine zu
tief ist auf die milliardeneinnahmen
durch den gas transit angewiesen ein
junger mann mit einer jüdischen keeper
ist in köln bei einem mutmaßlich
antisemitischen angriff schwer verletzt
worden aus einer etwa zehnköpfigen
gruppe heraus sei der 18 jährige am
freitagabend in einem park attackiert
worden teilte die polizei mit zwei junge
tatverdächtige wurden vorübergehend
festgenommen
der staatsschutz ermittelt
in den tarifkonflikt bei der bahn ist
bewegung gekommen
der konzern bot der
lokführergewerkschaft an über eine
corona prämie in diesem jahr zu
verhandeln und bat die gdl zugleich
dringend an den verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren die gewerkschaft wies das
angebot allerdings zurück und hält an
ihrem streik vorhaben fest somit müssen
sich bahnkunden auf den zweite streik
binnen kurzem auch im personenverkehr
einstellen ab heute nacht zwei uhr bis
mittwoch früh
die korona zahlen steigen täglich
betroffen sind derzeit vor allem
ungeimpfte und junge leute das robert
koch institut meldet
7050 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
2322 mehr als vor einer woche drei
weitere todesfälle kamen hinzu die
sieben tage incidents ist auf
54,5 gestiegen
die heiße wahlkampfphase hat begonnen
heute in fünf wochen wird an dieser
stelle das heute-journal wald sieger und
verlierer interview von heute aus
gesehen ist sehr gut möglich dass dann
noch keinesfalls fest steht wer
deutschland künftig in welcher
konstellation regieren wird denn das
rennen ist knapp der der den trend der
zeit auf seiner seite hat stellte sich
heute den fragen im zdf-sommerinterview
olaf scholz spd kanzlerkandidat und es
ging auch dabei natürlich zunächst um
das thema der woche afghanistan
wir alle haben die lage falsch
eingeschätzt so hatte es der
außenminister gesagt so hatte es die
kanzlerin gesagt olaf scholz sagt so
etwas nicht im zdf sommerinterview im
aufwind der umfragen versucht der
kandidat der stunde keinen fehler zu
machen und keinen gemacht zu haben warum
hatte für die bundesregierung die
evakuierung der ortskräfte solange keine
priorität es hatte priorität ich habe
die priorität gerade berichtet wie man
das hinbekommt und deshalb ist es ja
auch in der diskussion gewesen vom
verteidigungsministerium und
außenministerium zu gucken ob man die
frage der visaerteilung auch vor ort
hier in deutschland regeln kann das ist
jetzt auch so entschieden ich finde es
erschreckend herr scholz ist vizekanzler
dass finanzminister als solches gerät er
sich ja auch im bundestagswahlkampf
und natürlich muss er auch kritische
worte für den parteifreund finden denn
herr maas ist neben frau kramp
karrenbauer neben herrn seehofer und
neben herrn müller die person die dieses
chaos zu verantworten hat scholz
vermeidet es heute herrn mas zu
verteidigen der frage ob er ihn als
minister behalten will weicht er aus
jetzt geht es um die arbeiten hierzu
leisten ist und wie die nächste
regierung gebildet wird das entscheidet
sich nach der wahl die überaus heftige
kritik an der verschleppten evakuierung
ist für scholz vor allem deshalb ein
problem weil er sich im wahlkampf als
der erfahrenste der an packendste
kandidat präsentiert es ist der kern
seiner kampagne da gibt es eine partei
die die zukunft anpackt anpackt anpackt
darum ist es ganz wichtig dass wir das
anpacken anpacken anpacken was man
anpacken muss liebe freundinnen und
freunde dass scholz es packen könnte
galt lange als luftschloss aber die
schwäche der anderen ist seine stärke
die spd holt unübersehbar auf in der
kandidatenfrage liegt berbalk bei 16%
laschet bei 21 und scholz sogar bei 44
prozent
die ersten berater glauben die euphorie
bremsen zu müssen die fernsehdebatten
kommen noch die einzige gefahr die bei
olaf scholz ist dass er eben in diesen
duellen manchmal zu abgehoben wirkt
vielleicht zu kühl manche sagen arrogant
auf der anderen seite wird man sehen er
wird sich auch vorbereiten die spd folgt
scholz in diesem wahlkampf erstaunlich
diszipliniert nur selten werden
haarrisse sichtbar in der klimapolitik
der scholz am kohleausstieg
2038 festhalten parteichefin esken
bringt einen früheren ausstiegstermin
ins gespräch deutschland hat ein vertrag
geschlossen da geht endet das mit der
kohleverstromung spätestens 238 spät und
die frage ist kann und die frage waren
wir fertig werden hat nichts damit zu
tun ob man über diesen punkt diskutiert
sondern ob wir es schaffen dass wir
jetzt den ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien hinbekommen seit vier
wahlkämpfen ist kein sozialdemokrat dem
kanzleramt so nahe gekommen wie olaf
scholz jetzt gilt es keinen fehler zu
machen oder wenigstens keinen zuzugeben
im kampf gegen den klimawandel sieht
scholz vorerst also wir haben es gehört
kein spielraum den bis 2038 vereinbarten
kohleausstieg vorzuziehen seien cdu
konkurrent laschet verweist als
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und ausdrücklich
sohn eines bergmanns wie er betont auf
die schwierigkeiten des strukturwandels
und die grünen-kandidatin bernburg wirft
beiden die verschleppung der krise vor
der pole ausstieg müsse schneller kommen
wie schnell geht wandel in der
braunkohle region lausitz hat der
abschied vom kohleabbau längst begonnen
und es für viele mit ernüchterung und
unsicherheit verbunden ein
theaterprojekt macht dort mit
künstlerischen mitteln nun greifbar was
transformation für die menschen bedeutet
der kohlezug heißt das stück kohle
albrecht ist eingestiegen
[Musik]
aber auch so so können erde haben wir
gesagt
ich
hole schwingt wie scheiße ehrlich und
authentisch wollen sie sein schonungslos
ihre bühne alte schütt waggons auf
gleisen mitten im revier mitten in der
lausitz und der stoff könnte nicht
aktueller und brisanter sein bergbau
transformation klimawandel
durch die verbrennung von öl
und kohle
ist menschengemacht
und umwelt fanatiker stürmen den tagebau
und legen al-islam sich jahre nur für
die grube gearbeitet und jetzt kommt
dass die texte um szenen nicht
ausgedacht sondern entstanden aus
berichten von zwei zeugen berg frauen
und männern aus der region sowie
reinhard tischer
wir dürfen reinhard fischer an die
abbruchkante seiner ehemaligen grube
begleiten der tagebau ist noch aktiv
reinhard tischer vor zwei jahren in
rente gegangen narben in der landschaft
haben die tagebaue hinterlassen auch
narben auf den seelen der menschen hier
erzählt er uns
abgebaggert umgesiedelt ausgeholt die
einzigen helden der energiewirtschaft
degradiert zu klimakillern verbitterung
in kohlenstaub ist was bleibt
verständlich findet reiner tisch doch er
persönlich glaube an die notwendigkeit
des wandels nur nicht überstürzt
deswegen kann man so ein tagebau nicht
express 0 anhalten und aufhören die
kohle zu fördern sondern das muss
allmählich auslaufen und das muss die
die landschaft muss saniert werden damit
sie wieder nutzbar ist im theaterstück
bekommt jeder kumpel sein solo sein
resümee
man hat viel kohlenstoff gefressen aber
nicht geworden wir haben erst mal
zugehört werden den leuten zugehört
ihren geschichten zu gehört weil es uns
auch ein anliegen ist diese geschichte
als ein teil unserer kultur auch zu
dokumentieren und auch für die nächste
generation zu erzielen wertschätzung die
ankommt
das ist mein leben das ist mein leben
dargestellt gibt die gänsehaut wenn man
diese sehen und die woche hat und das
alles also das ist es ergreifen für mich
schnörkellos letters stück zum
diskutieren ein
mach dich theater wird zum vermittler
zwischen betroffenen gesellschaft und
politik es ist keine abrechnung und das
ist gut denn die geschichte ist nicht zu
ende
ja strukturwandel kulturell und hier
wird es jetzt sportlich gundela
in der fußball-bundesliga hat bayern
münchen gegen den ersten fc köln 3 2
gewonnen es war kein leichtes spiel für
den rekordmeister gegen mutige kölner
und in der anderen sonntagspartie
trennten sich hoffenheim und union
berlin 2 2 unentschieden
tennis olympiasieger alexander zverev
steht im finale des atp turniers von
cincinnati und bestätigt eine woche vor
den us open seine topform gestern gewann
er in einem dramatischen spiel das
halbfinale gegen den griechen zipp us es
war sein zehnter sieg in folge das
finale gegen den russen andrejew mit dem
zverev eine enge freundschaft verbindet
beginnt in kürze
tropensturm grace hat in mexiko
überschwemmungen erdrutsche und
stromausfälle verursacht mindestens acht
menschen kamen dort ums leben
unterdessen hat tropensturm rhi die
ostküste der usa erreicht die behörden
rechnen mit sturmfluten und
überschwemmungen die auch die metropole
new york treffen könnten wenn yakumo wie
in dem bundesstaat den notstand aus ein
konzert im central park musste vorzeitig
wegen starkregens abgebrochen werden
eigentlich wollte new york damit seine
wiedergeburt nach der korona krise
feiern
sie muss noch warten zum sonntag gehört
der blick auf die kommende woche dazu
zählt zum beispiel ein virtueller g7
gipfel am dienstag zur situation in
afghanistan drei weitere wichtige
ereignisse hat annegret oster
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
am dienstag werden in tokio die
paralympics starten an der
eröffnungszeremonie wird wie schon bei
den olympischen sommerspielen schirmherr
kaiser naruhito teilnehmen
134 sportlerinnen und sportler aus
deutschland haben sich bereits auf den
weg gemacht um in japan um medaillen zu
kämpfen
angesichts der explodierenden corona
zahlen werden auch die paralympics
weitgehend ohne zuschauer stattfinden
zum auftakt einer sondersitzung des
bundestags wird kanzlerin merkel am
mittwoch eine regierungserklärung zur
afghanistan-politik abgeben im anschluss
daran will das parlament das mandat für
den evakuierungseinsatz der bundeswehr
beraten und beschließen außerdem soll
über die verlängerung der epidemischen
lage von nationaler tragweite sowie über
den milliardenfonds für den wiederaufbau
nach der hochwasserkatastrophe
diskutiert werden
die kirchen in deutschland haben zu
einem bundesweiten gedenkakt für die
opfer der flutkatastrophe eingeladen am
samstag wird im aachener dom ein
ökumenischer gottesdienst stattfinden
daran teilnehmen werden der vorsitzende
der bischofskonferenz bätzing und der
ekd-vorsitzende bedford strohm
eingeladen sind außerdem
notfallseelsorger helfer und betroffene
der naturkatastrophe
und das wetter bleibt zum start in die
neue woche regnerisch und frisch der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor
ergiebigem dauerregen bis morgen abend
in vielen regionen ostdeutschlands
sonnen gibt es morgen nur ganz im norden
landeinwärts überwiegen die wolken und
vor allem im südosten regnet es örtlich
mit gewittern bei 16 bis 23 grad auch an
den kommenden tagen bleibt es ähnlich
frisch dienstag und mittwoch meist
freundlich am donnerstag wieder mehr
regen riecht nach herbst so viel von uns
nachrichten gibt's hier wieder um 00 40
und immer auf zdf heute.de und morgen
begrüßen sie an dieser stelle claus
kleber und kitesurfer richter
[Musik]